[Musique]
avec vous là une phrase bien sûr bonjour
allen bonjean pauline à la une de la
presse internationale hélène bien sûr
comme dans le journal de mariam pierrade
et on en parlait à l'instant le bilan
des négociations d'hier entre la russie
et l'ukraine qui sont tenus à istanbul
en turquie des pourparlers qualifiées de
substantielles par moscou l'opération
spéciale remplacé par la désescalade
grâce à la diplomatie
d'après nezavissimaïa gazeta les
négociations n'ont pas conduit un cessez
le feu mais aurait permis à l'ukraine et
à la russie de se rapprocher je cite
d'un compromis un tournant que le
quotidien russes attribuent en partie au
rôle important joué selon lui à la fois
par le président turc recep tayyip
erdogan et par l'oligarque russe roman
abramovitch 1 dont la presse américaine
a fait état en début de semaine du
possible empoisonnement lors de
précédentes négociations
le journal qui cite des sources turques
évoque même la possibilité d'une
rencontre prochaine entre le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky et vladimir
poutine qui pourrait avoir lieu en
turquie sous la houlette précisément de
recep tayyip erdogan oman
abramovitch doute on reviendra en détail
sur le parcours dans l'info est quoi
avec christophe dans cette app 7h45 les
discussions a dit hier hélène sont
présentés comme une éclaircie
diplomatique après plus d'un mois de
guerre la croix parle d'un espoir de
paix de la possibilité d'une trêve avec
d'importantes concessions côté ukrainien
le renoncement à l'otan et l'adoption
d'un statut de neutralité
le journal estime néanmoins qu'il serait
imprudent de se réjouir d'abord parce
que les états unis ont jeté un froid en
estimant qu'il y avait là un rien de
neuf ensuite parce que le don basse et
la crimée sont exclus des négociations
et enfin parce que vladimir poutine a
montré que l'imprévisibilité était pour
lui une arme comme les autres petite
lueur d'espoir titre le journal belge le
soir dont l'analyse est cependant
nettement plus nuancé en pages
intérieures puisque le quotidien évoque
une paix en fort ils ne paient encore
fort lointaine après des négociations au
parfum de coup politique russe lueur ou
leur l'igs les occidentaux prévient
libération attendent des signes concrets
de des escales est sur le terrain même
s'il est aux russes des crs sur l'ouest
du pays l'ukraine est à terre et plus de
4 millions de ses habitants ont été à se
pousser à se réfugier dans les pays
voisins rappelle le quotidien sans
compter que plus de mille mercenaires
russes de wagner aurait été déployés
dans l'est et que les combats risquent
d'être sans pitié le refus obstiné de
vladimir poutine d'ouvrir un corridor
humanitaire à mario paul où plus de cent
mille personnes seraient en train de
mourir de faim et d'épuisement n'est pas
de bonne augure
la bonne volonté je cite se mesure aussi
aux gestes de simple humanité
quelle photo à la une de libé la faim
qui menace aussi des millions de
personnes à travers la planète à cause
de la flambée des prix provoquée en
partie précisément par cette guerre en
ukraine l humanité dans le sillage des
nations unies alerte sur la façon dont
cette guerre en ukraine risque
d'aggraver les fractures mondiale le
journal voit dans le refus de plusieurs
pays africains de condamner
l'intervention russe le mali l'algérie
le soudan l'angola l'afrique du sud et
même le sénégal une manifestation de
cette fracture de ce schisme un
responsable de l'union africaine fait
état d'une vague pro russe au sein des
opinions publiques africaines sur fond
d'échec militaire des occidentaux dans
le sahel et des conséquences tragiques
subi par l'ensemble du continent
africain à cause de la guerre en libye
l'afrique frappe l'est frappés de plein
fouet par la pandémie où la popularité
réelle de vladimir poutine est en
réalité difficile à juger mais où toutes
les manifestations hostiles à
l'opération barkan ou à la france au
niger au burkina faso au mali ou au
sénégal était fleurie de drapeaux
pro-russe voire de slogans pro wagner
wagner la société militaire privée
soupçonnait d'être l'armée de l'ombre au
service du kremlin qui est également
très présente en centrafrique on a là
encore la guerre en ukraine se répercute
dans le pays haut des sources
concordantes ont indiqué au journal le
monde que le conflit est en ukraine est
en train de provoquer une réduction des
effectifs parmi les mercenaires de ce
groupe wagner une évolution qui pourrait
augurer soit une forme de repli de
réorganisation le journal indique que
les seulement dans lequel la guerre en
ukraine place la russie pourra l'amener
à essayer d'appuyer davantage les
ambitions de ses alliés ce dont
témoignerait la demande qui a été faite
au début de ce mois par deux membres de
l'ambassade de russie auprès de la
présidente de la cour constitutionnelle
de centrafrique sur les moyens de faire
sauter la limite de deux mandats
présidentiels une ambition qui
commencerait à s'affirmer dans
l'entourage du président touadéra selon
le quotidien le monde on ne se quittent
pas là dessus on a les matches de
barrages de la zone afrique et la zone
europe pour la coupe du monde de foot
avait lieu hier soir alors je vous
épargne l'ensemble des détails un mais
c'est juste un aperçu une pensée tout
d'abord pour nos amis algériens éliminé
à la toute dernière minute par le
cameroun une défaite amère et injuste
d'après liberté algérie on pleure à
alger mais on sourit à douala willy lite
on l'a fait exulter le jour quotidien
francophone comme ce titre ne
l'indiquent pas joua également à tunis
après la qualification des aigles de
carthage face aux aigles du mali rendez
vous à doha exulte la presse
destination doit aussi pauline pour le
portugal qui l'a emporté face à la
macédoine du nord 20ème étage d'où sogno
on poursuit le rêve titre ce matin le
quotidien sportif portugais a bola très
belle journée à tous ouais je vous
soupçonne hélène de favoritisme pour
l'équipe portugaise